hello one of the biggest problem today
is the lack of knowledge lack of
knowledge creates uncertainty the lack
of knowledge creates fears lack of
knowledge leads to the mistakes big and
small the lack of knowledge is a result
of lack of exchange of information there
are some people who don't like to
receive information when I'm talking
about them most of the people need and
want to have information and it's our
responsibility to create the
infrastructure to create the
circumstances for the free exchange of
information with free information flow
I believe that information society will
make our life better